I'm going to introduce some simple concept of geometrical optics to
help us understand how light traverses through the lens and
what happens on the other side of the lens after light has passed through it.
Let's look at a simple example schematic of a lens.
This is referred to as a principle axis and
we'll look at as light hits this lens and what happens on this side.
So this is a set,
is the principal axis is a point here which is also the focal length.
If you remember the whole concept of the pinhole, that's where we
want the image to be formed in the camera obscura pinhole camera.
In this case now when light hits through the lens let's see what happens.
So any light that's parallel to the principle axis, when it
hits the lens will converge to the point where the focal length of that lens is.
So parallel rays converge at the focal length point of a lens.
Any ray of light that goes through the point of the principal axis will go
through straight unchanged.
It will not have any deviations.
So any rays of light that basically pass through the center principal point of
a lens will traverse through without any divergence.
So, in essence, this is the point that behaves like a pinhole.